police in a South African Township
people run they know they shouldn't be
out and they know the consequences can
be harsh the lockdown rules here are
among the strictest in the world and
security forces are accused of using
excessive force several people have been
shot this young woman is so scared she
wants to remain anonymous she says
police beat her up with sticks after
finding her walking along the sidewalk I
was in pain if the police say harsh
tactics are needed in the townships if
they don't listen then unfortunately
those things happened I'm not saying
it's right and in some communities
that's all the members of the public
understand they need to see those things
unfortunately before they adhere to
instructions yes they need to see that
this is serious and the police are not
just telling you to go in vows because
you know it's a volatile instruction
police are out in force in Kenya to hear
they sometimes use tear gas to keep
people inside the capital Nairobi is
under lockdown no one is allowed to
leave or enter the city leaving some
stranded a student came back from abroad
for the Easter break but is now stuck in
her fourth week of extended the
government Kenya's president told the
nation tough measures were vital to stop
the virus spreading I know especially
when we introduced the curfew maybe in
the initial stages there were some
challenges and I want to apologize to
all Kenyans maybe for some excesses that
were conducted or happened in Madagascar
people set aside fear of catching the
virus from each other when authorities
briefly lifted a travel ban but fear
remained in control and Ivory Coast
where people in Abidjan destroyed a
testing center being built in their
neighborhood we are the people we don't
want the coronavirus here this is right
next to the people we don't want it we
don't want it today tomorrow we don't
want it the day after tomorrow that's
right we don't want it test test test is
the World Health Organization's simple
recipe for getting a grip on the
pandemic but in most countries they're
not enough test kits or laboratories to
process the kids South Africa leads the
continents testing drive officials have
fired up the country's large Health
Research and tracing facilities honed by
years of fighting HIV they're promoting
independent testing and it reports that
nurses are refusing to work in hospitals
and testing centers due to a lack of
protective gear
yeah I'm proud of myself for doing this
for the country
yes I'm association
by the end of April the South African
National Health Laboratory services said
it will be able to process about 36,000
tests a day at the same time the global
race to produce a vaccination is on
fears spread across the continent that
Africans would be used as guinea pigs
after to French doctors in a televised
debate suggest that the trials could be
carried out in Africa the
director-general of the World Health
Organization responded swiftly Africa
cannot and will not be a testing ground
for any vaccine we will follow all the
rules to test any vaccine or
therapeutics all over the world using
exactly the same route whether it's in
Europe Africa or wherever we will use
the same protocol and if there is a need
to be tested as well to treat human
beings the same way equally as the
vaccine is still a long way off some are
rushing to stock up on chloroquine
achieve anti-malaria medication after
promising early signs that it might help
fight curve at 19 in burkina faso this
wackadoo goo resident bought large stock
just in case by the time we get the
official approval for the product it
will already be available small studies
in France and China suggest it may
reduce the virus load
the patients under treatment especially
under specific treatment such as
hydroxychloroquine recover faster we
have found but I have to say when it
comes to science observation alone is
not enough an extensive research is
needed before a theory can be validated
validating attitude South Africa bikina
faso and cameroon have authorized
hospitals to use the drugs on
coronavirus patients but the World
Health Organization says more tests need
to
and it should also not be used at home
several people have died of side effects
after taking it without medical
supervision the biggest risk of
contagion isn't densely populated poorer
areas Cape Town's Khayelitsha was the
first South African Township to confirm
a Cove at 19 case it's nearly impossible
in places like this to keep physical
distance and maintain hygiene it's not
easy we try to stay in the shacks but
you can't you have to go out collect the
water come back you don't have candles
you have to go buy them quickly and come
back that's how we survive in the shacks
[Music]
yet hope and awareness are crucial to
and musicians across the continent like
Uganda's Bobby wine are producing
pitcher corona songs offering even
people living in shacks
[Music]
simple Michael is a simpleton
we'll break cameras it's important its
eyes employees and simple to use is that
everyone is a potential victim but a
corner is that everyone is a potential
solution
[Music]